not me but I'll make sure some of my
homies how long
homie I was gonna bracer death right
will dictate I make some of my homies
had this on at nighttime I got a Teflon
with a big old steel plate oh you like
that my name is Cena see you know ya see
you no no see I in are like a hundred
dollar bill okay I grew up in South
Central Los Angeles 14 both parents yeah
well I got Curtis brothers and stuff we
we stuck we start a gang we started it
was mostly a tagger game but the
detector we were there with a gang so
they wouldn't go on for it it was we
started gang a for a hard time hustlers
and they were mostly tagging riding on
the bus stop and stuff going to school
in our land so at the time I was
standing Hoover hood so they said you
either gonna be a Hoover or you ain't
gonna be nothing and stuff so I turned
to Hoover at that time we was Hoover
Crips and stuff so I turned who really
didn't know what I was getting into
seriously already didn't know what I was
getting into
if cuz
really following the fitting fitting in
protection and stuff like that
you got your homeboy and stuff and even
though I said I I say I don't know what
I'm getting to everybody around here
call me who you know no seriously and
it's hard with a person I really know
what they getting into cuz a lot of
people period person see you got people
everybody you got game everything you
got gangbangers see the difference you
got people that's gang members that
ain't there from the hood but they ain't
putting no work you know what I'm saying
and at the time I was growing up you had
to put in some work you know what I'm
saying at the time I was growing up like
I say no say no names you know it was
mostly dry box you know I don't sing and
stuff so I'll give you a hint
there's a difference between the dry
body and when you really do somebody
because I sprayed to a lot of people if
some men and Lord got to live with me
and the Lord
I say you ain't never really did nobody
okay
and stuff and then you wake up sweating
you can't sleep and stuff like that and
I I tell a lot of my youngsters dad you
know saying it's hard it's tough
it's it's really hard and stuff I say
you guys to get over there and I think
that's something you don't want a lot of
people kill except they can't live with
that they came in with Siri you can't I
say when you shoot somebody like this
and the Drybar you really don't know who
you shot will you really kill somebody
and stuff it's it's it's it's hard and
you know explain that to explain that to
him and [ __ ] like that and it's
something it's this hard this is hard
when I was growing up it was it ain't
like it is now it ain't like it was now
see I was growing up with using you as a
real gang banger he was a real gang
banger soon you know every gangbanger
hit the county deal so when you hit the
county jail he was a real game baker a
known gang banging you throwing a 4800
no seriously off the top he was going to
4800 and stuff I did you know and and I
tell our people you couldn't make it
people was getting right back then
really rate you know I'm saying it was
people getting really rank stuff that I
received that stuff it's like he was
really getting raped this stuff and like
I say
praise it I see people get tortured on
the street no I mean you know lost and
tortured when I mean by 20 the air scout
scout no scalp my homie
really we made you come up with that it
went it when the problem come on pops
work that night my with moms she lit up
keep guns in the house my mother left
key guns in the house so it wasn't a
problem with guns nothing like that I
always made it a point to come home
after 2:30 in the afternoon because my
father would be going to work there I
tried to avoid him
no he was I just
he was more strict he was more extreme
then my mother was more lenient you know
I don't see so I know I could get away
if I came you know if I can't with him
are spurned in the house like this when
he was gone and stuff and I I mean one
time I went to deal and under my
mattress under my mattress like there I
had about four gun
when I got where I got really get a deal
my father said don't even come here
seriously he told me don't even come
here he explained to me like that
and to be point well battle oh he knew I
got a from okay I stole him for my
next-door neighbor who was this year he
I stole him for my next door neighbor
who would escape he knew okay for who
were walking sliced in a bank it's nice
to hear
sliced here and at the time
these are stress
because I only had a friend just shot
right next to me it's not only I had one
my closer to me get shot right next to
me I'm gonna say his name no mouse
you shot closer to me like this it blood
on you and I ran right you know always
not came back it's because a female come
from West he was tracked riding and I
said and I'm like is he alright but I'm
still panicking it's done I'm still
panicking see a lot of people put on
that [ __ ] stuff like they super and I
really know that's not you that's not
cute
okay that's not that's not - you see we
do a gang banger so whole thing your
whole clan your whole mentality change
how you talking everything you know how
you talk how you write and everything
I'd never ride a boat I'll give it to my
uncle [ __ ] in your name you then go
write that oh no you ain't gonna write
that oh if you want senior if you like
that Oh spell your name in school to you
o hasta X out on me
you ain't gonna write it in I mean
seriously when you see is about it
you ain't gonna write it in or in eight
you okay a neighbor a neighborhood ain't
right at three or eight without crossing
it out hey when you say who it for fear
no it put fear cuz we play tennis pro
killers you know saying anybody killer
so it put fear in here okay
I would one how do I wanted to read it
in a County Jail LA County Jail
okay dad they had to separate us from
another game we had our own court had a
hope or no leaped out mm what augh
so you messed up it say you were from
Hoover they look at that mm oh you know
it's gonna happen too
because they messed up he came here
no telling what's not happening to you
you'll see
hi I'm behind with you I just any kind I
just stuck a bunch dig up any in amigo
but a number who was innocent a number
who was on this whole mortality
it's utter like others - little you know
me cuz I went there which I gonna do to
me I didn't get that you know I did I
mean people
I'm a gonna be straight my piss you know
stripping naked and I did that like I
say I did stuff okay
really I don't want to think that God
come talk to me ask me about oh the only
one okay pretty time let me give you
here how would the pretty
ninety how would the level one I was a
level way okay put it this way I went
from a level one to a level folk I
skipped two and three
no seriously I went from minus 0.2 one
hundred and seventy seven points okay
I was on some of the roughest yards I've
been Pelican Bay caress the city I've
been a suitable up there twice I that's
high desert though level four 189 270
what eighty I've been a new folks on
that's current valley enough for all the
hardcore is that people talk about
Pelican Bay it's like this no Pelican
Bay ain't like this cuz you unlock down
but all the point for who well okay you
ain't on lockdown
okay when I get there
first thing I'd say I need that burner I
need a bluer straight up
I need a pool okay I've been told I'll
kill myself with a nun affiliate that I
had a blower but your glorious right
floor is like a weapon I'll blow is like
a knife
jisu knife you know how many say we
don't see him I'm not talking about a
ranger
I might um power raised on the
toothbrush yeah I'm not talking about a
raise another toothbrush okay I don't
have I didn't have to get people off the
crew from who ain't have to get people
off the yard
you wouldn't believe what the other two
that was with me about to do say I'm
gonna get him I had a homie
tarlyn j-roc could have been a
professional bodybuilder still he feel
intimidated and make a noise so we had
to get him up the yard at high death so
one of my homies duck said I mean I'm
trying to go to a level three other home
ec I'm not trying to go home in there hi
Devon everybody knows something 50 go
down
Ganga police right here get everybody on
the side they get out of the room so we
walk in the track then we get here I go
it happened on a Tuesday I go home
Friday I go home Friday you have to get
him off so when they said that I would I
got man
why not you get him off you get him on
okay at that time I did not have to blow
her and I pop with the distance you know
I'm saying and nobody had we got them
all they shot they shot stuff
like this detail my attitude and stuff
where it got me
my neighbor but for my life and I said
sheesh
well said he's stupid you supposed to go
home just like this you could went home
just like there and he went like this he
a my attitude sent me how much time I
got still going for you if I knew he had
thank you my thoughts they keep talking
ain't going nowhere now I had to be
honest with you I didn't got discipline
for a second I did in a pen okay I get
into it with somebody I'm working in the
kitchen and it goes like this happen
yeah I didn't come out hungry Bobby hit
the yard so when I was coming home from
work mama said come and I got discipline
you know I'll see it cuz I got into it
with a person and it was in here I
didn't say that day I let it go can I
lost and my pride was hurt
I'll also anger go tell home it's
standing here next day just wait though
and really I think that it wasn't
disciplining what you do too
we need this place they wanted to they
one wanted to her
really but they say I took the
discipline that stuff like I took him
and he said yes because we only going
home and I and I think God if I wouldn't
it was fun getting a gang I turn that
got the road you want to follow down and
I spent or nice paid to what you gonna
get out of game you go get back from
prison you locate kill your family can
get killed your mama house can shatter
it's more better stuff than a gay be be
yourself don't be a follower
be yourself I think 99% of person and
gangers a flower